l'allemagne sous cloche pour pâques une
annonce qui sonne comme un mauvais jeu
de mots mais c'est la mesure prise par
la chancelière après 12 heures d'âpres
négociations avec les länder ce mardi
nous sommes juste avant pâques et la
question est de savoir si nous pouvons
transformer ces jours de pâques en une
période de calme
c'est pourquoi nous avons longuement
discuté de la manière dont nous pouvons
contribuer à atténuer cette troisième
vague dans laquelle nous nous trouvons
actuellement et que nous ne parviendrons
pas écraser complètement
c'est la raison pour laquelle le 1er
avril le jeudi saint et le 3 avril sont
déclarés pour une fois seulement jours
fériés avec une interdiction de contact
élargi ainsi qu'une interdiction de
rassemblement avec toutes ces mesures
cela offre du 1er au 5 avril pas mal de
repos sur la période de pâques une
nouvelle pandémie plus l'état les plus
sains t'excuses selon les mots de la
chancelière avec un taux d'incidence qui
a été nié lundi ce 107,3 cas pour 100000
personnes avec plus de 7500 nouveaux cas
et 50 décès des chiffres en constante
hausse ces dernières semaines notamment
en raison des nouveaux variants une
situation difficilement toléré par les
amont notamment les professionnels du
tourisme qui ont exprimé leur ras-le-bol
lors d'une manifestation
imaginez seulement que pendant deux ans
vous devez vivre sans revenus que ce
soit en tant qu'individu en tant
qu'employé ou bien moi même en tant que
propriétaire ce n'est pas possible ce
n'est plus une vie
c'est pour ça qu'il faut réfléchir à de
nouvelles alternatives en coopération
nous ne sommes pas des adversaires du
gouvernement fédéral et de l'industrie
du voyage
enfin de nos hôtels sont actuellement
ouverts seulement avec des réservations
qui suffisent tout juste à couvrir le
salaire du personnel et les coûts fixes
et ça ne peut pas durer éternellement
nous avons besoin d' annonce et de
directives claires de la part des
politiques
et ce au niveau européen et pas
seulement en allemagne mais pour le
gouvernement pas question de faire
marche arrière
appliqué depuis fin 2020 les
restrictions comme les limitations de
participation à des réunions privées
la fermeture des magasins dits non
essentiels et la clôture des lieux de
culture et de loisirs sont prolongés au
moins jusqu'au 18 avril
l'hypothèse de couvre-feu locaux a de
son côté été écarté tout comme la
fermeture des établissements scolaires